faiths Facebook syrian-israeli cyber
surveillance firm for allegedly hacking
users of its encrypted messaging service
whatsapp files in San Francisco as the
first legal action of its kind according
to Facebook says they grouped into the
phones of roughly 1400 users targeting
human rights activists political
dissident journalists journalist
tomorrow showed she was killed inside
Saudi Arabia's consulate in Istanbul in
2018 he filed a lawsuit against the
hacking of my phone they played a major
role in what happened to Jamal not
directly denied hacking legations to
fight them ITR Japan he says this
evidence needed to conclude the
allegations against NSO are actually
true I don't have any specific
information about the NSO group whether
or not they've been involved in this
directly or not but this company is a
company that sells spyware to
governments and in Latin America in the
Middle East and in other places so while
I think it's possible I still think
we're gonna need to see a little bit
more of the evidence that's behind these
allegations I would also point out that
this lawsuit was filed in San Francisco
and in what kind of jurisdiction they
may or may not have over an Israeli
company over something that happened in
the third country is also somewhat
dubious I would say every time you look
at what's up and you send a message you
see a message on your screen saying that
yes don't worry this is end-to-end
encrypted but now the company's coming
out and saying well but actually we were
hacked and we're suing somebody so the
key message here to consumers to
businesses and to governments that these
apps that you're using that you're
probably sending sensitive information
on every day are not nearly as secure as
they claim that they are and that you
think that they are I think nothing is
technically foolproof is is the first
thing that I would say but I think that
what we've also seen a lot of use is the
apps telegram the Hong Kong protesters
are using this and a lot of other social
movements around the world have been
using telegram because
of the fact that they're not storing
data on a central server which i think
is one of the deleting secure apps out
there at the moment